switching gears now from fires to
natural disasters even delivering blood
the red cross is always on the lookout
for more volunteers now they're honoring
a dozen of them encouraging everyone to
donate volunteer give blood or take a
life-saving class
the red cross is known around the globe
for the assistance it provides often in
the most dire circumstances every year
chapters across the country including
southern nevada's recognize 12
distinguished volunteers it's no easy
task according to executive director
rachel flanagan we could not do what we
do without them they actually make up
more than 90 percent of our workforce
southern nevada's chapter has 628
volunteers during a virtual ceremony the
american red cross honored these 12
individuals for their commitment to
responding during the past year's
destructive wildfire season supporting
disaster relief nationwide and
responding to local home fires
delivering services all while navigating
the worldwide pandemic people like stan
smith the board chairman he championed
our recent battle of the badge's blood
drive which brought in 176 units of
blood in one day nikki morachnik had
more than 3 300 hours of on-call time
she responds to fires all over the
valley and makes people feel absolutely
incredible and she's done this year over
year over year
the red cross looking for additional
volunteers people willing to come out
and train and respond on fires like
nikki and the agency is also looking for
folks to deliver blood to 10 area
hospitals that is a constant need you
can set that up dependent upon your own
schedule to learn more about
volunteering at the american red cross
go to our website at eight newsnow dot
com we have a link set up for you